okay everybody it is an exciting day if
you are a slack shareholder or
it might be disappointing because people
thought slack was going to be this
independent company that grew forever
and
maybe became worth hundreds of millions
of dollars but
it seems the company with the headwinds
of
microsoft teams constantly blowing them
back
and the inability to grow really fast
they seem to have put themselves in a
position to
be forced to be acquired by a larger
company
this news broke in the wall street
journal
last wednesday november 25th and it's
expected to be announced as i said
tomorrow december 1st depending on when
you're listening to this
according to cnbc's david faber
and so it's supposed to be a half cash
half stock deal
and it will price slack at a premium the
market cap
as of today's close about 24 billion and
salesforce was
223 billion so this would be worth
approximately 10
of salesforce's enterprise value
and the deal is supposed to be in the 17
to 25 billion range
i've heard a bunch of different numbers
the stock has obviously popped
massively prior to the sales forces
largest acquisition was tableau
which they bought for close to 16
billion back in 2019
and you have to ask yourself why why are
they doing this well
in many cases a big company will make a
big bet like this because they
can because they have a market cap
because they have access to capital
and because keeping it out of the hands
of competitors is also important
what if microsoft what if google
facebook or another company ibm were to
own
slack this could be problematic for
salesforce because slack is so
so ingrained in next generation startups
and mid-size companies it is how
companies run it's really the operating
system
of remote teams when you are on a remote
team you live
and breathe inside of slack now since
the pandemic happened you would think
that slack would have surged but it
didn't for some reason and i think it's
microsoft
teams i've only had one company out of
maybe 200 active companies we've
invested in 150 maybe are active
out of the 200 plus we've invested in
i've only had one team actually invite
me to a microsoft teams call
and it was kind of zoom like and i
understand they have a slack like
features but i don't see
a lot of microsoft teams in the small
startup
space but we do see absolutely slack is
the standard
and why didn't slack become big like
something like zoom did during this
break i have no idea the product seems
to be a bit stagnant and super confusing
if you're not part of this culture
so i think the product always had this
headwind of being a little too
complicated
for people to understand and the product
team although they made a really great
world-class product it seemed like they
were going very slow
some things were kludgy and maybe a
little janky on the
on the margins like inviting other teams
to your team slack so you want to have
your accountant or your law firm
or maybe two companies are working on a
joint project together and they want to
be in the same slack room
it was super confusing and i've actually
had these discussions with
uh stuart from slack on publicly on
twitter and he's very responsive to it i
also said just a couple weeks ago maybe
two weeks ago i said to him why isn't
there like a universal url so i could be
people.slack.com jason just like i have
a twitter url twitter.com he's like oh
we're working on that
that's definitely in the works that
universal identifier where i had a
profile
and everybody would uh be able to follow
that profile and that profile would
follow me from organization to
organization
really cool because if i were to leave a
job
i'd still have my slack profile i could
still have followers i could still have
conversations with people
outside of my work that would have been
a great vision but
it feels like slack maybe couldn't get
and couldn't scale to that next level
now they were doing
if you look at you know the amount of uh
revenue is pretty amazing that you know
they they were at 200 million dollars a
quarter in revenue
if you look at that run rate of you know
800 million
dollars or so in revenue in other words
in a year they do 800 million well 24
billion dollar market cap like we're
talking about here would be 30 times
revenue
think about that right three times eight
is 24 you've had a couple zeros boom
so 30 times revenue and so if you look
at salesforce their run rate is 20
billion in revenue that's a lot of
revenue right more than 20 times what
slack has and they're giving them
basically 10
of the organization's value so that
makes you wonder why is this
why are they doing this because they're
currently salesforce is valued at
11 times their revenue right so their
market caps 223 billion they've got 20
billion so that's 11x
then you again look at slack 800 million
24x there's got to be a theory here a
thesis